je reste un peu à compte courant et
raisonnement optimiste par rapport à ce
qui vient d'être dit si on sort de
l'affaire elle-même quand on regarde le
contexte la presse a fait son travail
la justice est en train de faire son
travail l'Inspection Générale a fait son
travail et le Parlement fait son travail
le Sénat a décidé par une décision du
bureau sur suggestion du président
rennal avec l'accord unanime unanime de
la commission des finances de l'ancienne
Commission d'enquête et là on est en
train de reconstruire le dispositif donc
moi je crois que si je devais tirer
une conséquence au moins positive pour
pas désespérer Billancourt nos
concitoyens c'est de dire oui finalement
on a des contre-pouvoirs qui
fonctionnent et un sénat qui sur
l'affaire Benalla sur la question des
concessions d'autoroute sur l'affaire
hors PA et en première ligne pour faire
son travail et souvent le sénateur le
député là en l'occurrence le sénateur et
perçu comme étant un parlementaire un
peu de la Haute Assemblée donc un peu
haut dans la pratique il est un garant
des libertés et aussi de rééquilibrage
des institutions donc finalement y
compris sur des situations difficiles
comme celles que nous vivons avec cette
affaire des fonds Mariannes le Parlement
fait son travail je veux structurer nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent en disant
vous avez des parlementaires qui font
leur travail des journalistes qui font
leur travail et on a également la
justice chacun dans ses pouvoirs qui
font qui font leur travail
respectivement je crois qu'il faut aussi
réenchanter un peu le monde et dire que
nos institutions ne sont pas totalement
corrompus à côté de la plaque ou de leur
engagement mais ils sont là présentes
pour rééquilibrer quand c'est nécessaire
ça a été
[Musique]